we're now facing an emergency just as we
thought we had turned a corner probably
the most significant threat we've had
since the start of the pandemic the
omicron variant is continuing to rip
through the uk population the emergence
of omicron omicron
the questions now will england face new
restrictions would boris johnson even be
able to deliver them and could christmas
be cancelled again
[Music]
england's plan b restrictions mean
covert certificates
work from home guidance and compulsory
face masks in more places
the hope was not this would stop omicron
but slow it enough to get more booster
jabs in more arms
early evidence suggests that to protect
yourself from the variant three jabs are
far more effective than two
but with fears that cases may reach a
million a day by the middle of the month
some scientists are wondering will plan
b be enough the numbers that we see on
data over the next few days will be
quite staggering compared to
the rate of growth that we've seen in
cases for previous variants this is a
record number of cases i'm afraid we
have to be realistic that records will
be broken a lot
reports suggest some in government are
considering plan b plus
what this is remains unclear but it
could involve
checking in at hospitality venues using
the covert 19 app
table service only in restaurants and
bars
face masks in school classrooms
currently it's just in communal spaces
and hospitality venues accepting only
proof of vaccination and not the results
of a negative lateral flow test that
would be highly controversial
[Music]
come on give me a cuddle
last year in england and scotland the
government introduced christmas day
bubbles of a maximum of three households
it was two in wales but those living in
tier four including in london were
banned from mixing at all
soon after in january 2021 the
government introduced a national
lockdown to try to slow the spread of
the alpha or kent variant
but now there are even more cases than
back then
over 56 000 earlier this month compared
to just over 20 000 the year before
the difference of course is now a
significant majority of the british
public have had at least two doses of a
covered vaccine but with data about the
impact of the omicron variant still
insufficient christmas plans for some
have been thrown in doubt again
the scottish government is advising
people to limit socializing to three
households in the run-up to christmas
i am asking i am appealing to everyone
to cut down as far as possible our
contacts with people in other households
now that is guidance it's advice not the
law but it may be an approach the uk
government is tempted to follow
elsewhere in europe austria has
controversially lifted its lockdown on
vaccinated people only
meaning those without jabs have to stay
in lockdown
in greece unvaccinated people face fines
which has drawn criticism from across
the political spectrum
and in the netherlands a lockdown has
been extended
and yet in south africa
medical officers have appeared bemused
by europe's response certainly a whole
lot of infections but what this country
hasn't seen is high numbers of
hospitalizations in fact i can tell you
that here in halting central south
africa the hospitals are taking patients
with other conditions with other
illnesses i mean they're functioning as
normal
the uk has stepped up its booster
program so that anyone over the age of
18 is eligible
leading to some long queues
they told me it's going to be a couple
of hours
but i'll give it a try
[Music]
101 tory mps rebelled against a
three-line whip the eyes to the right
306
the nose to the left 126.
an enormous expression of disapproval
from boris johnson's own side mr speaker
if it wasn't for labor votes his
government
wouldn't have been able to introduce
vital health measures we need to save
lays and protect the nhs
if cases continue to rise the prime
minister might struggle to persuade his
own mps but more restrictions are needed
being dependent on labour support is a
position no prime minister wants to be
in
there are suggestions some tory mps
rebelled because of labour support
giving them political cover to register
their disapproval of the prime minister
without actually defeating him
but after a series of damaging reports
of christmas parties in downing street
and conservative headquarters last year
one senior tory mp says boris johnson
could face a leadership challenge in the
new year if he doesn't change he's got
to now be in some danger and he's got to
realize that because if he doesn't
realize that then he will be in much
bigger danger
while it seems unlikely christmas will
be cancelled warnings from the
scientists may mean some celebrations
are curtailed whether boris johnson
introduces further restrictions or not
concerns about covid seem to be changing
behaviour leading some to scale back
their christmas plans
foreign